what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and still talking
about sony's spider-verse sony
spider-verse kind of took a hit after
morbius and especially after morbius's
re-release did not do so well in the
theaters but guess what sony is not
stopping anytime soon and today we have
huge news about venom 3 and this news is
coming directly from tom hardy himself
and this is actually really really big
news for this sony spider-verse in
general because tom hardy has teased
spider-man and this is great news this
is what tom hardy has been talking about
for over a year now he's been talking
about venom 3 being a spider-man movie
but there's a lot of twists that we have
to talk about and it does look like this
is unfortunately going to be tom hardy's
last movie as venom which is unfortunate
because with the exception of spider-man
no way home in the spider-man homecoming
trilogy venom is the best thing to come
from sony in a very long time but there
are some things that you have to know
about venom 3 about spider-man about the
mcu and the sony spider-verse and we're
going to break it all down in this video
and of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest venom spider-man and
marvel news so first things first let's
talk about the venom three news and how
it came about tom hardy shared this
picture on his instagram and although it
may not seem like much it actually does
give us quite a bit of information here
also you can still currently see this
picture on his instagram as i'm
recording this tom hardy has a history
of posting things to his instagram and
then deleting them this has been kind of
fun in the past but also kind of a pain
in the butt because it's led to people
photoshopping photos and putting his
instagram handle at the top making it
seem like he posted something but he
actually really didn't leading to a lot
of misinformation out there but as of
right now as i'm recording this it is on
his instagram page we have a little
hand-drawn picture of venom at the top
and then it says story by tom hardy and
kelly marcel written by kelly marcel now
if you were a fan of venom let there be
carnage you will be happy about this
because tom hardy and kelly marcel wrote
venom let there be carnage and now
they're both coming back and teaming up
to write venom 3. now what's really
interesting about this is that there's a
little hand drawn in red ink s on the
little hand-drawn venom face and we are
assuming that this can only mean one
thing spider-man as i mentioned tom
hardy has been teasing venom vs
spider-man for a very very long time now
since before venom let there be carnage
even came out when he was doing
interviews for the movie he teased that
the next thing and probably final thing
was going to be venom going up against
spider-man finally the sony verse for
venom kind of changed the whole origin
for venom how the symbiote got to earth
who it first attached to how eddie brock
bonded with the symbiote of course a lot
of people know that originally peter
parker aka spider-man was the first
person that the symbiote bonded to peter
parker eventually realized what the
symbiote was and that it was bad and got
rid of it in which the venom symbiote
then spent pretty much the rest of its
life mad at peter parker and trying to
get revenge on him he hated him for
rejecting him so it's kind of like i
love you but i hate you type of thing
but obviously since the first venom came
out we saw that the first person that
the symbiote bonded with was eddie brock
and we have not seen spider-man since
however the post-credits scene for venom
let there be carnage which was kind of a
slap to our face teased that eddie brock
and venom would be going up against the
mcu's tom hollands peter parker
everybody got really excited this is
what we were waiting for but then the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home completely changed that and that's
what we have to talk about that is so
important tom hardy's eddie brock and
the venom symbiote got sent back to the
sony spiderburst however they did leave
a little piece of symbiote behind this
tells us that the mcu and the sony verse
are truly going to remain separated with
the exception of the other spiderman
showing up in spiderman no way home they
want to keep the universes separated so
there is going to be a different venom
in the mcu but tom hardy's eddie brock
and the venom that we know are going to
remain in the spider verse and this
means two different things that are
really really important one is that tom
holland spider-man won't be the
spider-man in the sony verse which
leaves it open for a new spider-man
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
two it also means that there's going to
be a new venom in the mcu and since it
was the post-credits scene for
spider-man no way home spider-man 3
we're all assuming that spider-man 4
with tom hollands and daiya and jacob
battle on is going to be about venom a
new venom and this is where we could be
getting that new comic accurate story
where the venom symbiote first bonds
with spider-man slash peter parker he
rejects it and it goes on to find eddie
brock and both marvel studios and some
executives at sony said that they do
want to start working on that spider-man
4 movie very soon and they've already
started to kind of work on the
development of it already kevin feige
and amy pasquale already confirmed this
because they didn't want fans to think
that sony and marvel weren't working
well together again they confirmed that
they are and they're already planning
the fourth spider-man film and not too
long ago some executives from sony did
say that they hope to start very soon on
spider-man 4. so it's really interesting
because it does kind of look like
spider-man 4 with tom holland is going
to be a spider-man vs venom film but at
the same time venom 3 with tom hardy
looks to be a venom vs spider-man film
as well but since spider-man 4's venom
isn't going to be tom hardy that means
that venom 3 spider-man isn't going to
be tom holland and this is kind of a
bummer i think a lot of us were
expecting tom hardy's venom to go up
against tom hall and spider-man but it's
looking like that's not what we're going
to get however that does leave room for
a new spider-man in the sony spider-man
universe now since andrew garfield and
toby maguire return for spider-man noway
home this means that it could be one of
them however i'm gonna go ahead and rule
out toby mcguire at least not for the
main spider-man of that movie because
we've already had a venom movie with
tobey maguire spider-man i don't think
they would do that i don't think they'd
bring him back for another spider-man vs
venom movie and besides he does look
kind of older now however people really
really loved andrew garfield's
performance as spider-man in no way home
and we're very excited to see him back
and he did mention that he's open to
returning and we've heard from some
insiders that sony is considering using
andrew garfield for other projects in
the sony verse so it could be andrew
garfield spider-man that we're getting
for venom vs spider-man and after all we
did have that scene in spider-man no way
home where toby maguire talked about
fighting venom an alien and tom holland
talked about fighting an alien thanos
and andrew garfield had that line about
him wanting to fight an alien well looks
like he might get that opportunity in
venom three and of course there is
always the option that sony might get a
new spider-man altogether now at this
point in time i don't think this would
be a very good idea people really love
tom holland spider-man and of course the
mcu is going to continue to make
spider-man movies and like i said people
love the return of andrew garfield
spider-man so introducing an entirely
new spider-man probably would not be the
best idea i think the best idea at this
point would be to simply go with andrew
garfield toby mcguire got his venom
movie looks like tom holland's about to
get his venom movie in the mcu give
andrew garfield his venom movie going up
against tom hardy and venom three after
all it still is a venom movie tom
hardy's eddie brock should be the main
focus still but you should get an iconic
spider-man in there not just a
spider-man that nobody knows and is new
to the universe that's what i think they
should do and that's what i'm hoping
they do now there is one other piece to
this news today according to
thedirect.com
tom hardy did at one point post the
script to his instagram story that has
now been taken down but apparently when
it was up it had a sticker over it that
said last dance and if this is true if
that truly was on tom hardy's instagram
story in which they did take a
screenshot so if it's not photoshopped
that means that this is going to be the
last venom movie for tom hardy which is
sad to think about because again venom
is the best thing to come from sony's
universe and i think tom hardy is great
but let me know what you think about all
of this news in the comments down below
let me know who you would like to see
play spider-man in venom 3 going up
against tom hardy leave your thoughts
comments and theories down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest venom and spiderman news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof